das ist nicht wahr ich denke jeder von
euch hat das neueste video von bibi
gesehen
[Musik]
richtig meine damen und herren bibi
pflanzt einen baum habe ich zuerst
gedacht dann habe ich das video weiter
geschaut und habe gesehen wo die ist
schwanger
und mit den ganzen reaktionen auf dieses
video dies von allen medien gab ihnen
wie in deutschland also wirklich überall
war alles voll damit hey baby und juden
sind schwanger sie erwarten ein kind
blablabla habe ich auch sehr viele
kommentare bekomme ich soll darauf
reagieren und als ich dann diese ganzen
kommentare gesehen habe habe ich bin
einfach nur gedacht hey nein das ist
deren kind als wenn ich auf einen
ungeborenes kind reagieren also jetzt
mal ganz im ernst freunde viele leute
kamen wirklich zu mir an und meinte hey
lukas schon mitbekommen wie mir
schwanger hat dies das blabla reagiert
er doch mal drauf du machst dich doch
sonst auch über die lustig ja über ihren
content mache ich mich lustig in so gut
wie jeder reaction auf ein video von
bibi oder von baby und julian zusammen
habe ich immer gesagt ich habe nichts
gegen die personen an sich ich habe noch
nie mit denen so richtig gesprochen
außerdem mal kurz irgendwie bei einer
party oder sondern ich habe mich immer
lediglich auf ihren content bezogen und
wenn sie dann irgendwie mal was dummes
gemacht hat dann habe ich dann halt
drauf reagiert und habe sie dann gibt es
nun vom ausgelacht dafür und aber das
ist jetzt wirklich eine sache das ist
jetzt raus gekommen und ich muss ehrlich
sagen damit habe ich nicht gerechnet ich
dachte halt ehrlich gesagt als sie diese
komischen teaser videos hochgeladen hat
also diese beiden videos da wurde nichts
passiert ist eigentlich dachte ich
ehrlich gesagt im ersten moment immer
jetzt kommt vielleicht eine neue sorte
bio oder vielleicht sogar neben blu
kommt jetzt noch ein parfüm von ihr auf
den markt und das ist wieder so eine
heftige marketing promo aktionen das
hätte ich wirklich gedacht doch als dann
dieses video kam wo ganz klar gezeigt
wird am ende sie hat einen bauch und ist
schwanger ich glaube damit hätten wir
alle nicht gerechnet also man kann sich
jetzt drüber streiten ob es cool ist
sage ich mal so zwei teaser videos
hochzuladen so eine art promo-aktion
dafür und dann so sagen dass man ein
kind auf die welt bringt ich weiß ja
dass jetzt so cool ist aber das ist
jedem selbst überlassen und ich bin ganz
ehrlich an dieser stelle
und julian ich freue mich wirklich mega
für euch ich also meinen augen gibt es
nichts größeres das habe ich auch schon
häufig in interviews gesagt das worauf
ich mich am meisten freue in meinem
leben ist einfach wenn mein eigener mein
eigenes kind egal ob sitzen mädchen oder
ein junge ist wenn ich das einfach sehe
das findet sich so schnulzig hier werden
oder irgendwie was aber bibi und julian
ganze ernst ich feiere teuren konnte
immer noch nicht so mega aber dass ihrem
kind bekommt ich freue mich mega fight
ich habe die ganze zeit gegrinst als ich
mir dieses video angeguckt habe außer
wirklich zu beginn wohl verlangen
einfach durch seinen wald spazieren
gegangen seid da dachte ich wirklich im
kauft baum und pflanzen euch den garten
oder irgendwie so aber freunde das war
es auch schon also das ist wirklich
meine reaktion auf baby ist schwanger
changes baby und julian bekommen ein
kind wie auch immer ihr das ganze thema
sage ich mal nennen wollt ich freue mich
mega bbb und julian das einzige was ich
jetzt ein bisschen bedenklich an der
ganzen sache finde und das hat auch
länger in seinem streamen gesagt ist das
möchte ich euch nur ans herz legen bibi
und julian bitte zeigt euer kind nicht
bis es ein gewisses alter erreicht hat
und darüber einer gewissen form sage ich
mal selbst entscheiden kann natürlich
bin ich selber kein vater und bin doch
nicht ansatzweise in der position
irgendwelche erziehungsrat schläge hier
zu verteilen aber ich wenn ich ein kind
kriegen würde würde ich glaube ich
wirklich so lange verdeckt halten wie es
irgendwie geht und es auch nicht auf
youtube zeigen weil es ist ein mensch
der sein kind was vielleicht später
nicht möchte dass videos von ihm
existieren wie es laufen lernt oder wie
es zum ersten mal aufs klo geht oder
keine ahnung was aber ich will hier gar
nicht mehr so lange drum rum la es kam
nur recht viele leute an und meinen
nicht seinen vorstellungen nehme ich
habe baby heute ist sonntag der bi zum
muttertag gratuliert ich freue mich mega
4 und julian allerdings werde ich jetzt
nicht aufhören auf dem nächsten mal auf
irgendwelche bescheuerten videos von
euch zu reagieren das ist wie gesagt
nichts persönliches aber meine damen und
herren
ich möchte hier natürlich nicht so ein
blödes statement hier einfach bringen
und sagen dass ich darauf nicht
reagieren möchten dass ich nicht wegen
foul sondern wir schauen uns mal an wie
das kind von den beiden überhaupt
aussehen könnte und dafür befinden wir
uns immer wieder auf der webseite murphy
bot
wir sehen hier schon den chat verlauf
vom letzten video bei murphy wort ist es
nämlich so dass sie beispielsweise
solche bilder generiert bekommen wenn
man beispielsweise ein tipp jfw
beautycase kontrakte was diese website
also runtergebrochen einfach macht ist
ein mann gibt einen satz ein wie
beispielsweise what if petrus jesus
christus und dann wird eine mischung aus
petrus und jesus christus also wieso bin
ich jetzt geradezu religiös unterwegs
deswegen geben wir jetzt einfach mal
eine rotte bianca heinecke julian klasen
heißt er glaube ich das heißt wir gehen
jetzt einfach mal ein fragezeichen eine
die website überlegt jetzt ein paar
sekunden später
das ist nicht meine damen und herren das
kind von babys beauty palace und julian
co könnte so aussehen
juli an mit babys gesicht allerdings
gibt uns der murphy bord noch einige
weitere möglichkeiten dieses bild
anzupassen und zwar können wir
beispielsweise diesem smiley hier
eintippen also einfach ein gesicht was
nach unten zeigt das heißt es gebe ich
jetzt einfach mal ein und nun macht
diese website ein etwas anderes foto
daraus ein paar sekunden später
haben
das ist natürlich auch ein tolles kind
allerdings habe ich mich natürlich jetzt
gerade nicht lumpen lassen und habe noch
mal einen traurigen 2d eingegeben und
dann kam das hier raus vielleicht hat
das kind einfach kein gesicht ich habe
jetzt hier nochmal smiley eingegeben
allerdings meint der murphy bot story
einem out of ideas trüffeln question das
heißt wir geben jetzt eine what if
julian klasen bianca heinicke also
einfach mal umgekehrt das ganze eingeben
mal schauen was jetzt raus kommt denn
jetzt sind er quasi ein bild von bibi
als unterlage sag ich mal und julians
gesicht darüber und oh mein gott
das ist ein
normal bibi oder ich habe jetzt einfach
mal eingegeben wortes julian cope with
duty palace um zu schauen was dabei raus
kommt man mit den richtigen namen hat er
uns nur baby gerade angezeigt und da
kamen dass hier das sieht echt hart
verstören aus allerdings habe ich jetzt
mal wieder einen traurigen smiley
eingegeben das heißt wir haben jetzt
wieder als grundlage sage ich mal wie
die perle ist allerdings dass rom
rickert
das ist jetzt sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig
genauso gewöhnungsbedürftig wie die
tatsache dass bibi in ihren nächsten
videos jetzt einfach im bauch haben wird
also einen richtig dicken bauch ich
meine ihr müsst euch überlegen sie ist
im sechsten monat
das heißt drei monate lang wird der
bauch noch dicker
ich hab grad mal gemeinsam überlegt
freunde eine schwangerschaft ist ja
einfach voll das krasse ding
überlegt euch mal das ist der bauch von
der frau oder von dem mädchen in dem
fall ich mein baby ts 25 und der wird
einfach ticker weil da ein mensch drin
wächst das ist natürlich okay so
pflanzte sich menschen seit jeher fort
so aber wenn man mal drüber nachdenken
ist es hat komisch irgendwie ich weiß
nicht ob ich das so sehe aber ist ja
auch komplett egal wir kommen zurück zum
sport und zwar habe ich beim hafen bot
mal wieder einen traurigen smiley
eingegeben unterkamen das hier
ich dass das ist eine sache an die ich
mich echt noch hart gewöhnen muss was
wir allerdings auch noch einen geben
können ist einfach ein trauriger smiley
und fenster hinter das heißt dann
realisiert der murphy bot quasi okay ich
soll nicht den hintergrund ändern
sondern das bild also nicht das bild
sondern das gesicht
also wenn wir den gleichen hintergrund
immer noch baby aber mit einem angesicht
von julian khol sieht hammer aus der ist
da gerade ein bad oder so ich habe das
ganze ist einfach noch mal eingegeben
also noch mal 1000 smiley und fällt das
ist ein mensch mit zwei augenbrauen an
der stelle mich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren an der stelle ein dickes hockey
sage ich mal erhält man das so nennen
kann dann alle leute die jetzt irgendwie
gedacht haben ich würde mich über bibi
und julian lustig machen dass sie
bekennt haben aber nein das ist ein
mensch den sie auf die welt bringen das
ist krass ich feiere das und bibi und
julian ich wünsche euch ganz ganz viel
glück und ganz ganz viel erfolg in
dieser beziehung sage ich mal jetzt als
familie ich denke dass sich das kind
sehr sehr wohl fühlen wird bei euch ihr
seid ja wirklich also so wie ihr rüber
kommt echt liebenswerte person sehr
lustige menschen auf die ich auch sehr
gerne mal reagiere weil die user noch
teilweise echt hart bescheuert sind aber
das war es jetzt auch hier von meiner
reaktion nämlich jetzt nicht direkt mir
das video changes hier live mit euch
angeguckt sondern eher so ein paar
ausschnitte gezeigt und das thema
allgemein behandelt ein paar screenshots
gezeigt er ich hoffe ich habe es auch
gefallen dass ich zwischendurch das so
ein bisschen hippie worten und
reingebracht habe um so ein bisschen zu
prognostizieren wie könnte das kind
aussehen das wird natürlich nicht so
aussehen aber ist natürlich eine lustige
idee ich feiere die marriott auf jeden
fall mega und ich weiß auch das baby und
julian dass jetzt mehr oder weniger
öffentlich gemacht haben weil man sollte
es natürlich auch nicht krampfhaft
verstecken und man will natürlich auch
frei sein und deswegen will ich damit
jetzt auch das video beenden schreibt
mir eure meinung zu dem ganzen thema
gern mal und in die kommentare lassen
like da wenn es euch gefallen hat und
vielleicht zu einer nächste reaktion von
einem video von bibi und julia wo sie
wieder irgendeinen schwachsinn
das war so das war's jetzt ihr vom video
hier können jetzt hier bei den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]